foreign
if you get out of debt your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income if you invest a hundred dollars a
month from age 25 to age 65 in a decent
growth stock mutual fund it will be one
million one hundred seventy six thousand
dollars you retire a millionaire 25 to
65. but you can't have a 750 F-150
payment
you can't have a student loan that's
been around so long you think it's a pet
a Master Card
American distress or discovered bondage
you can't just keep yourself in payments
where all you do is work for the man all
you do is work for these stinking banks
that have better furniture and bigger
buildings than you do the reason is you
gave them all your stinking money
and you have no money because you gave
it all of them and that has been what
we've become known for because it's the
single largest blocker for folks out
there and debt has been so normalized in
our culture that to even imagine living
without it is unbelievable
and uh article just handed To Us by our
producer yesterday the New York fed
released its q1 report on household debt
includes a record high
17 trillion dollar
Consumer Debt balance in America today
so I'm we're doing no good
because I mean we're not even making a
dent
apparently we're going to be in business
forever this is for 17. job security
trillion dollars with persistent credit
card debt and Rising delinquency rates
it's where we're at and it's it's wild
that says in here a typical first
quarter sees credit card balances
decline as people pay off what they
spend over the holidays while trying to
out gift their in-laws but for the first
time ever the New York fed stated that
tracking this for 20 years this isn't
the case this year so for the first time
instead balances remain flat over q1
suggesting that people aren't cutting
back and are probably using credit cards
to finance daily spending due to the
right to the rising cost of pretty much
everything
and so
it and I feel like
this is where when the inflation
conversation started about 18 months ago
here on this show
the fear was that people were going to
more than ever
justify take that margin that was there
and now isn't there
and continue to live a lifestyle and
make up that difference with credit
cards yeah but let's be real clear here
the debt is not because of inflation the
debt is because you're wussed out and
refused to cut your freaking lifestyle
to offset inflation
because you're still sitting in a line
of 30 cars to buy an unbelievably
expensive cup of coffee
and yet I'm in debt because of inflation
now you're in debt because you didn't
cut your spending when inflation hits
you that's why you're in debt so this is
not an outside variable that is
controlling your life it's you not
controlling the variables in your life
and so your butt ends up in yeah and
what sucks is you know for a lot of
people though it's not this outrageous
lifestyle that they're living you know
that there's two incomes they have kids
they have family like they are living
life the quote-unquote American standard
of living that again you can we can
argue the standard of living of what it
is but
what's difficult is when you have to go
backwards nobody likes to go backwards
that's why that's why I feel outrageous
because it felt normal that's yes and so
when you actually
consider the way we all live yes it's
outrageous white crazy styles are
outrageous when you look at the standard
you know the the square the average
square footage should I can I can I can
I get a word in I don't know can you
well barely barely but no but you look
at the average square footage in the 70s
now average car average vacations I mean
you look at all of it and it has the
American lifestyle has gone up and so
our expectations on what is normal is
here and so for families that are living
paycheck to paycheck that are doing this
and sure because you know you have a 600
car loan like there there is still debt
in the picture that is causing less
margin but when something like inflation
hits and eggs and bacon everything goes
up in your grocery bill is like what and
to fill up your car you're looking at
the gas you're like what that's done in
the moment like that does hurt because
there's not the margin for that extra
hundred extra 200 extra 300 that now is
going out on normal expenses so so to
cut back which I agree with you but it
feels like but I
what am I supposed to cut back to
because because
where I'm where I am you know normalized
outrageous yes we've become exp we
became uh entitled to outrageous and so
I'm entitled to this and and so you know
inflation then forced me
to go into debt which is absolute
hogwash you just did not I mean all it
is is you have to address you have to
look in the mirror and go we just buy
some really stupid stuff I mean we
really buy some stupid stuff well most
people in most countries could exist for
a year off of the crap that's in your
garage that you've not even seen in a
year
you know I mean we buy some stupid stuff
so yes it's normalized it doesn't feel
outrageous but it is outrageous so I I
always resist when Bank rates senior
industry and analyst says uh suggesting
that people aren't cutting back and
using credit cards is it's because of
the rising cost of inflation no they're
not cutting back to offset inflation
duper that's what's really going on and
so you know and I get it I it's not fair
I don't like inflation I don't want that
to take your check away from you but
don't be a victim you're not a victim
you're a victim of the person in your
mirror and the idea here's here's
another plan if you think getting into
debt to maintain your lifestyle is going
to maintain your lifestyle there's an
end to that there's a mathematical end
to that it eventually comes in but it's
a boomerang comes back around smacks you
in the head and says hey dummy yeah
family's out there though because I mean
I was sitting down with a family they
made 80 000 and you look at you look at
month to month after taxes you know and
you're looking you're like okay like
everything on their budget was not
unreasonable right I'm like it's an hour
current it's a family of five and it's
like yeah this is what a Costco this is
what it takes to feed the family this is
what you know granted the kids are doing
a sport like I mean like it's life it's
just it is life and life is expensive
and so families out there that are
listening it's like if you when you're
feeling that pressure that you felt even
before inflation and then add some of
this on here where life got even more
expensive you have to evaluate needs
versus wants and this is where we've
Blended so much that our what we want
has become a need and so being able to
prioritize and really look
and it's and it's hard but it's like
okay what really are our needs and we
talk about the four walls food shelter
utilities and transportation and then
under that there has to be a priority
because in order for you to sleep at
night and to actually have peace and
control your money is so much worth it
than some of this other stuff that's in
your budget and so cutting some of that
for the time being it's probably a
reality to help you get on the other
side of this it doesn't have to be
forever but depending on the credit card
and and functioning in that cycle of
I'll just use the credit card to to
offset the stuff it gets you into more
trouble and less peace killing yourself
yep killing yourself
dad is not your answer
this is the Ramsay show